[Music]  [Applause]  i've never seen that are you serious  i've never seen that enough it was  luckily i had been booed before  so it wasn't a new thing so i remember  just afterwards  thinking about it going like why didn't  i let that fat guy boom me i let that  chick with the weird glasses like why  didn't i say something i just remember  thinking i was just mad at myself so  here's the funny thing so we still had  one more date on that tour and it was  like as i walked out on stage everybody  booed because they wanted me to trash  their  city so then it became this thing's like  i can't do this again or then this is my  act this is like gallagher smashing the  watermelon that was the one i freaked  out about because i thought it was like  i thought my career was over i was like  everywhere i go i'm gonna get booed i'm  glad that people enjoyed it because i  was definitely i was embarrassed that  the whole thing happened